questa sera vi vogliamo parlare di
un'isola di un'isola che potrebbe non
esserci più
e quest isola
è un'isola tra i dieci
[Musica]
la sera vi raccontiamo di questo viaggio
è proprio un isola di ghiaccio parte da
lì
nello specifico il ghiacciaio presena in
trentino
e val di sole
che la comunità scientifica
internazionale ha
scoperto essere uno tra i primi nei
ghiacciai planetaria estinguersi da qui
a circa 10 15 anni
il dato allarmante che solo la comunità
scientifica sembra
di cui solo la comunità scientifica sia
della sera è consapevole che l'effetto
domino che si creerà da questa
estensione
oltre che essere pericolosissima
irreversibile con un enorme danno su
tutto l'ecosistema nel quale abitiamo
quindi noi abbiamo voluto portare un
intervento
d'arte perché artisti siamo e
soprattutto di condivisione con le
comunità che vivono questi luoghi con le
aziende per il turismo
che lavorano in questi luoghi con i
turisti con le comunità scientifica
appunto per tentare di aiutare
la comunità scientifica a diffondere
questo messaggio e naturalmente noi che
siamo romantici artisti che abbiamo dato
anche una valente politica scrivendo un
manifesto sull'elemento principale ossia
l'acqua
[Musica]
abbiamo scelto un luogo
un luogo
emblematico un luogo che fosse
l'epicentro di tutto questo processo che
andiamo a raccontare questo luogo a
3.000 metri di altezza è l'avviso re del
pejo 3000
a pejo 3000 abbiamo deciso dopo un lungo
percorso insieme alle guide del parco
nazionale dello stelvio di prendere
questo luogo come epicentro e come cassa
di risonanza dell'esperienza che abbiamo
fatto appunto seguendo le vie dell'acqua
abbiamo esplorato fiumi laghi ghiacciai
cascate e l'idea di pejo 3000 è stata
una scelta
abbastanza audace perché non è un posto
ospitale e quindi bisogna prendersene
cura e avere attenzione
l'idea è stata quella di creare un
auditorium con delle sculture per far sì
che queste possono risuonare le
esperienze avute proprio sul territorio
con delle residenze che abbiamo fatto
dai vini fino arrivare ragazzi più
grandi sono state delle scuole di
scrittura scrittura musicale sempre
incentrate sul tema dell'acqua perché
come abbiamo detto prima l'acqua è
l'elemento che più di ogni altro va in
profondità e insieme all'acqua abbiamo
voluto unire il suono quindi un elemento
materiale è un materiale che hanno in
comune la potenza di andare non essere
bloccati oltrepassare bene quindi questa
esperienza di scrittura musicale è
diventata poi un brano sinfonico scritto
arrangiato e poi perché strato per
l'accademia teatro alla scala insieme al
coro di voci bianche
tutto questo percorso è diventato quindi
un brano sinfonico che suona all'interno
delle sculture le sculture sono un punto
di contatto tra la natura quindi gli
elementi naturali ossia l'acqua il
ghiaccio e la neve il vento la potenza
delle montagne e il suono perché
all'interno hanno un impianto audio che
risuona il brano uno di un milione
quindi lo spettatore ogni volta che
andrà a pejo 3000 potrà avere delle
emozioni delle sensazioni diverse in
base alle condizioni climatiche le
sculture non sono un luogo di riparo di
rifugio anzi hanno dei tagli anno sono
fatte in ferro acciaio appunto per
esaltare anche il freddo far passare
l'aria attraverso le fessure il ghiaccio
entra dentro quindi uno stando dentro le
sculture in realtà entra ancora più a
contatto con quello che è elemento
fondamentale e sul quale dobbiamo avere
attenzione ossia l'acqua siamo riusciti
ad accendere vico riusciti perché è
stato un percorso abbastanza complesso
appunto per quello che stiamo dicendo
che il problema delle condizioni
climatiche e del climate change perché
l'idea da quella di inaugurare i primi
di giugno con
il coro di voci bianche dell'accademia
alla scala proprio 3000 metri ma la neve
è stata
la regina del
di giugno di fine giugno addirittura
quindi abbiamo deciso di aspettare i
tempi della natura gestire la situazione
con molta calma ma con attenzione e
quindi 3 di luglio siamo riusciti a
portare sui ragazzi dell'accademia e far
diventare le sculture una specie di
evoluzione naturale di tutto il processo
che c'è stato all'interno della valle e
delle comunità e vi farei vedere
l'inaugurazione
[Musica]
allora molta messo su questo laboratorio
in questa avventura perché è stata
un'avventura durata anche parecchi anni
riuscire a costruire tutto questo
il nostro desiderio era ed è
come trasferire questi segnali da questo
laboratorio da questioni centro di
trasmissione
verso
tutta una serie di
connessioni diverse lungo la penisola
lungo ogni isola lungo il pianeta
oggi non siamo qui per caso perché
sicuramente la sicilia è una di quelle
isole che prima di tutte si connette a
questo nostro segnale per tre motivi il
primo per l'idea originale di questo di
tutto questo lungo processo è nata
proprio in farm cultural park
e tutta la crew secondo motivo perché
collettivo di cui stiamo parlando di
quindi facciamo solo parte nei due nasce
tra berlino e la farm cultural park
terzo motivo
perché siamo ospiti di questo
meraviglioso ha detto naturalmente e
cene in realtà un quarto e ossia che il
gruppo diciamo di innovazione
tecnologica con cui abbiamo sviluppato
il modo di portare fuori
questi segnali e proprio siciliano ed è
un gruppo di innovazione che lavora san
cataldo il gruppo pop up
con il quale stiamo sviluppando proprio
il modo di veicolare fuori tutti questi
segnali
come abbiamo pensato di farlo con questa
con una borraccia
anche due per vari motivi
primo perché ci sembrava l'oggetto
migliore per poter
racchiudere tutte le gocce d'acqua che
abbiamo raccolto la sopra
secondo motivo perché abbiamo potuto
geolocalizzare tutte le vie dell'acqua e
tutte le vie verso i ghiacciai
con l'esplorazione dei quali abbiamo
potuto mettere in piedi tutto questo
e terza cosa che forse la più creativa
di tutte perché abbiamo deciso di
scorporare questo brano sinfonico che
c'è stato con l'accademia teatro alla
scala in migliaia e migliaia di note
e fare in modo che ogni persona
che entra in contatto con noi entra in
contatto con questo processo entra in
contatto con questa borraccia si
identifichi in una nota di questo brano
sinfonico
come
c'è uno
speciale quarkode
ma non importa che sono le vediamo
attraverso il quale
possiamo entrare in una piattaforma e
quindi scoprire gli elementi dell'acqua
gli elementi delle note dell'orchestra
sinfonica
i percorsi le esplorazioni che hanno
reso possibile questa esperienza
ed entrando in questa piattaforma
la nostra identità di persone diventa
una nota la nostra nota personale in
questo caso la nota di diletta
unica e che fa parte di questo
[Musica]
questa è la mia pista
e questo aiuterà a sviluppare tutto il
brano sinfonico
[Musica]
dopo di che passeremo appunto alla
scoperta e la geolocalizzazione di tutti
i percorsi di tutte le avventure che con
la comunità della val di sole e di di
quei luoghi ci hanno permesso di
realizzare questa
avventura
per poi arrivare alla fine naturalmente
a svelare l'intero brano sinfonico una
volta che le migliaia e migliaia e
migliaia di persone si permetteranno
alla mostra
[Musica]
perché è importante tu una nota non è
solo romanticismo non è solo
chiamiamo l'arte
noi abbiamo sempre pensato di affrontare
questo tema
nel modo in cui potevamo realizzarlo al
meglio utilizzando e lavorando con
un'orchestra sinfonica perché perché
l'orchestra sinfonica è oggi uno dei
rarissimi esempi in cui una collettività
usa le proprie
capacità e competenze personali verso un
fine comune in un'orchestra sinfonica
non esiste il protagonismo personale
esiste infine esiste il direttore
d'orchestra che ti porta all esecuzione
del brano questa ci sembrava un'ottima
analogia per poter proprio immaginare
una comunità uno di un milione che
potesse
permettersi di porre le proprie capacità
personali verso un bene comune un fine
comune che naturalmente è il tema da cui
siamo partiti che cosa possiamo fare
insieme per rendere reversibile gli
effetti così negative del climate change
quindi tu una nota questo è chiaramente
un tentativo un invito a partecipare noi
stiamo portando il nostro pezzo verso un
tema planetario cerchiamo di portarlo in
modo personale si chiama riportato
comunque
cercando proprio di dare una via che è
sicuramente una via molto il materiale
la nota le note ma anche materiale con
la capacità per esempio di morgana di
mettere a terra perché a un certo punto
tutti questi pensieri vanno messi a
terra che ci vuole proprio una stazione
che non solo riceveva dati ma li sappia
trasmettere quindi mi associo a
sicuramente il meraviglioso invito che
ci ha prima donato
mastroieni
non è vero che solo
mors tua vita mea ma possiamo veramente
creare una collettività che attraverso
le proprie individuali capacità possa
arrivare un obiettivo comune
grazie grazie